he's better off losing than having a mom
that doesn't think he can do it losing
is good you're right you shouldn't tell
him what to do you should tell him how
you would do it and then let him decide
how he will do it sometimes that's the
only good thing that's the part that
[ __ ] Mom's up you don't want him to
fall in his ass the best thing that
could happen to him is he falls on his
ass even if he goes into death of course
first of all if you're telling him
everything that he's doing wrong and he
starts going into debt slowly he's going
to know that you are right and he's not
going to go as deep into debt as you
think every second you're over
protecting him is more of him becoming a
losing fighter debt is good for him he
has no other option what are you going
to over coddle him to the Grave he's
going to end up being insecure because
he's going to think his mom never
believed in him because he is seeing
through your actions that you're over
cuddling him thus meaning you don't
think he can do it